Prince William and Harry were younger
and in their informative years you know
very similar to lots of other people of
that age you know we would say you know
what's happening this weekend don't know
yet okay
any idea no waiting on a phone call
which you know on a Friday and Saturday
evening a lot of other younger people
are also in exactly the same position oh
we we may be going to the cinema we may
be going to this restaurant we may be
going to this Pub for a drink and maybe
going to my friend's house and then you
get the phone call no I'm going out
okay where are you going don't know yet
but we need to Head West Chelsea Fulham
yeah yeah let's go you know and you're
you're wandering out not 100 knowing
what you're doing which you know really
puts up the or rather you know what
you're doing as a Protection Team you
just don't know where you're going to